with more than 530 million users a
social networking site LinkedIn is
gaining to new members every second the
man behind the company success is CEO
Jeff Weiner he joined the company back
in 2008 and is incorporated compassion
into his philosophy of leading his
employees
we traveled to linkedin's Silicon Valley
headquarters in California and talked
with this very unique CEO about his
unique management style I had never
heard the term compassionate leadership
until I met you and started reading
about you what is it exactly
compassionate management compassionate
leadership is about taking the time to
put yourself in another person's shoes I
think within a company a business a team
I like to do that to help the other
person achieve their objective or
achieve what it is that you're trying to
accomplish together more effectively is
it fair to say that compassionate
leadership and compassion has always
been your strong suit mr. Jeff Weiner I
was reading about you they said you know
he can be harsh he used to be his
reputation he was harsh and he used his
intelligence as a blunt instrument that
was hurtful is that a fair criticism of
you yeah a word that you didn't mention
I would have thrown in there for good
measure as were rattling off that list
of things I could do better very intense
and the intensity wasn't always
channeled a constructive way I'm still
intense but I'm more conscious of how to
manifest that intensity more
constructively in just eight years CEO
Jeff Weiner has grown LinkedIn small
staff of 338 to over 11,000 employees in
various offices around the world today
it's important that we laugh and have
fun while we're doing what we do or at
least are in an environment where we can
try to have some fun I love that fun I
could see in this serve I was in trouble
includes a ping pong tables whoa at
their Silicon Valley headquarters wait a
minute okay you don't have to name names
but it's okay if you want to what what
do you think are the biggest mistakes
that CEOs make I think speaking from my
own experience
the biggest lesson I've learned in the
role of the CEO is not to leave the
pitcher in the game for too long but no
pitcher says take me out coach I'm ready
to come no pitchers is that okay mr.
compassionate leader how do you fire
somebody compassionately why don't you
let them go I like to in those moments
sit down with the person and be as
transparent as possible but there's
gonna be a timetable and you know
dependent person depend on the role
depending the gap that timetable may
shift and between now and the end of
that timetable I'm gonna be just
completely open with you in terms of how
you're doing because we're in this
together and if for whatever reason it
doesn't work out maybe we can look for
another role for you within the
organization and maybe it means
transitioning you out of the
organization under Jeff's leadership
LinkedIn has expanded substantially the
professional networking site recently
introduced a new feature for its 500
million users
I saw headline the other day that said
wait is LinkedIn becoming the new
Instagram that there are some changes at
LinkedIn that now you're adding a video
component so as soon as we started
rolling it out we saw members creating
their own shows what did you learn today
okay so I learned a couple of things one
I need to play a bigger game and really
revamp my LinkedIn profile we saw
members creating the most innovative in
such clever video resumes we saw a
designer for example go to a whiteboard
and do all this really clever animation
last month Jeff Weiner joined fellow
Silicon Valley CEOs calling on Congress
to pass the bipartisan DREAM Act we are
living in a time where there are a lot
of changes specifically now talking
about daca where there seems to be a lot
of anti-immigration rhetoric feelings in
this country what do you say to that
some of these young adults who were born
in this country were brought to this
country certainly wasn't their choice
are some of the most inspiring talented
people I know and I've had the privilege
to meet 40 percent of the fortune 500
was founded by immigrants or the
children of immigrants so you think
about all the value that's been created
as a result of people who were seeking a
better life for themselves and their
families and the people that they're
responsible for
it's how the United States was built
that's Jeff Weiner he's one of the few
CEOs I know that's gotten a 100%
favorable rating from his employees in
the past and to show you something about
how he operates he had a 14 million
dollar stuff stock bonus last year
instead of taking it home to his wife
and two gorgeous daughters he put it in
a company pool put it back to the
company pools and they sold themselves
to Microsoft for 19 billion dollars yep
that was a whole big secret that it
didn't leak out because of the key
insight you did that together but he's
quite all of this stuff about Jeff what
I loved was learning about you and good
I played as a kid Jeff can beat me he's
very good but we had a ping-pong table
at home and I love the game this is like
things about Gail King I did not know
after all these years I'm so mysterious
we play a lot of ping-pong in our house
but my house too do you have a table in
my office yeah come on over to see my
sketching but I love the game charlie I
love I do too I really enjoy playing it
yeah